Tom Holland didn't hit the Hollywood
scene so much as he smashed into it at
speed kind of like a meteor with
charisma but for all the sparkle of his
ride to the top there's still a lot we
don't know about the actor here's the
real story behind Marvel's youngest
leading light apparently Tom Holland has
been dancing since he was in diapers in
an interview with The Hollywood Reporter
he recalled that he used to dance to a
Janet Jackson song that his mother would
play when he was a baby this ended up
prompting her to enroll him in a weekly
dance class for children which Holland
took to immediately throwing himself
into everything from ballet to hip-hop
with feverish intensity and although
this was the first step on the road to
becoming one of the world's most famous
actors it was also something schoolyard
bullies were quick to jump on at the
time luckily as he told People magazine
you couldn't hit me hard enough to stop
me from doing it it was this relentless
pursuit of his passion that pushed him
to audition for the titular role in the
West End production of Billy Elliot got
him doing back flips and his audition
tapes for Marvel and ultimately gave him
real-life experience as an underdog
something he now credits as a key
inspiration in his performances Peter
Parker Pollan told People magazine I
like Peter excepted I wasn't the cool
kid at school and just found my group of
friends and got on with it you wouldn't
guess it from the way he seems to revere
every new experience Fame brings him but
Tom isn't the first famous Holland nor
is he the only one who's worked in the
creative arts his father Dominic is a
comedian broadcaster and author while
his mother Nicola
Elizabeth is a photographer despite his
early exposure to the world the
performance and his enrolment in that
weekly dance class Tom's ascent has been
described by his father as a fluke total
fluke what's happened to my son Tom a
real fluke yeah because there's been no
stage school there's been no drama
lessons when Tom's agent proposed
putting together an audition tape for
Marvel the family was roundly skeptical
but now that the impossible has happened
the Holland's credit this unlikely
trajectory is the source of Tom's
down-to-earth nature there are few
superhero costumes quite as iconic as
spider-man's
that's one of the reasons it's barely
changed since its introduction in 1962
from the bold color scheme to the
dramatically flared eyes it was an
instant classic from the moment it
debuted putting on that suit has got to
be pretty daunting for
any newcomer to the role well though
just happen what was that you jumped off
the sign and landed on your face but
it's not just a figurative burden it's
an entirely literal one too in an
interview with shortlist Pollard
revealed that it never occurred to the
crew that he'd need a way to drink in a
suit a problem which demanded a complex
solution a hole is drilled in the eye of
the mask a tube is fed through and an
assistant squeezes water into Holland's
mouth but the consequences of all that
guzzling are just as problematic to
answer nature's call Hollen must strip
down to his regulation underwear which
is nothing more than a thong slap on a
bathrobe and book it to the nearest
bathroom and back as fast as you can
however he's quick to point out that
this hardship is outweighed by the
privilege of getting to bring the iconic
webslinger to life but when you trot off
to see him do his thing in Avengers end
game just remember the spider-man you're
watching probably just took a sip
through the world's most professional
crazy straw everyone knows that Holland
is a pretty goofy guy he's renowned for
his playfulness with Marvel movie
spoilers he's always ready to slap on
some vinyl shorts and perform Rihanna's
Umbrella with the best of them and he
can even find the humor in having to
drink through a straw that someone else
operates for him but it's not all fun
and games
Colin also has some serious ambitions
kid
revenger
he told The Hollywood Reporter the
20-year goal is to be a film director
the 15 year goal is to win an Oscar the
five-year goal is to just keep enjoying
myself he also went on to detail his
acting role models such as Leonardo
DiCaprio Jake Gyllenhaal and Meryl
Streep one thing is clear above all else
Hollen wants to be big he's ready to
work for it and he has a plan as to just
how he's going to accomplish it
Holland didn't expect to ever reach the
peaks of Fame he's already conquered let
alone hit them in his early 20s but it
really can't be emphasized enough that
up until Captain America civil war in
which Holland made his debut as
spider-man he really thought he'd go on
living the life he'd always led
interviews done to promote the
impossible reveal a 16 year old Holland
still certain he's going to go back home
to Kingston and finish up high school
while continuing to pursue his dreams on
the side looking back it's clear that
since Billy Elliott Holland has been on
a speeding train to blockbuster success
after every new production and role he
appears to have thought that things were
going to go back to normal except they
never really did it's only in recent
interviews that Holland seems to have
become someone who truly understands
that his life as he knew it is gone and
that fame is his new normal check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stop are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]